for me the person and its brain you to
see we are our brain and we need to
preserve it for decades and maybe 400
years I do not believe that crowns will
work but I do not believe that it will
not work we have to operate in this gray
zone
reowww transhumanism is not used on hope
transhumanism is built on suffering
breaking yourself in the process and
rebuilding yourself
time has come for people to accept that
death is no longer about just dying and
being bored in the ground but it's
really about choice
if you do decide that you want to freeze
yourself and try to live forever you
have two options you can go to the
United States where they have some
high-end facilities or you can come here
to Russia this is the town of Sergei a
facade on the outskirts of Moscow and
it's inside of this white warehouse
where you can chill out and wait for the
future to come
the patients and cryonics storage here
sign a contract with a company called
kryder's that's in force until the end
of time or at least until the
singularity comes so what is the
singularity well every day we're
building smarter and smarter machines
faster and faster at some point they're
gonna catch up with us that moment is
the singularity the transhumanist
movement can't wait for it to come for
us to reach the point where we can
upload our brains to computers and live
in harmony with machines it's inside
these two tanks where crier is has a mix
of humans and animals for $30,000 you
can have your whole body stored your
feet or placed up top and your head ends
up down here where it's coolest for half
that price you can store just your head
prior roosters actually had quite a few
takers for its service in here there are
30 heads 20 bodies six dogs three cats a
hummingbird and a chinchilla
she would name the Elise no she chose to
self-assess no Valen of top- to miss do
mosquitoes to Manhattan Oh nobody tosses
[ __ ] show at the Whitney Museum this
Muslims to me come to Manhattan
miss meteorologist read the past mission
columnist from dead not good - tough
legislation practically post-op
pregnancy room capital boo naturally no
fish no we got a canal Roberto just as
much positive and bright annuity when it
comes to prognostication the Russians
had a head start in the 19th century
bakwin's are still ruled the Russian
Empire a reclusive bookworm named
Nikolai fiora was the first
transhumanist he wrote that humans would
go to space and colonize other planets
would steer our own evolution with
technology and yes live forever
he suggested that humanity will destroy
itself unless there is a common project
that unites it and the best project he
can he could come up with was to defeat
death the little-known in his time Theo
derives influence spread through Russian
culture he was pen pals with Dostoevsky
and Tolstoy later his writing inspired a
movement called cosmos of Lenin led the
Bolsheviks to revolution with the cosmas
utopian vision of the future in mind
when the space race started their ideas
went mainstream and the Soviet Union
used them to stake their claim in space
many Russians are romantic more Russians
than say Americans and they have a kind
of a romantic attitude to science there
was a kind of culture of science in
Soviet Union the humans who are going to
be gods not gods of religion but the
gods of science and technology
rezian abortion irresolute seated in a
shop negates normal activity finished of
the yearly yes to me what Cervino versed
in the USA toys Adam would say Tom
Buster smirkin American is Abner inertia
which can move over
for some God do you have to show my
similar poetic vision you see the
premium is reason if the most karoo by
which new movie idea will gain at
interior stuff with the elude approach
the hooded Roboto gauge from Beauty
wheelers are suspected which is huge now
the new one which mysteriously smoke by
the edge still cannot operate of still
attached to butyrate remotely previously
led just [ __ ] allergy UK rock and
rock to Japan pissin twisting and name
is Athena that Parker Kuwait epochal in
LEDs motion study smeared them Moy
motion studies near the savage watching
dog shortly attribution non Sargon is
not sent a straight set the problem
arises study career assistance miss Kate
Virginia my mind Sarah vodka
nanotechnologies man's a shitty Buddha
she cherry status custom in selecting
interest no oceans mines have seen
Hughes to lose non-stop abolition as
both yet on house
you cannot start humans projects by
yourself but you have to get order
people and the best way to do is just to
show that this grand vision this idea of
cosmic development and then this all
fits together my team at was so the
palace Nepal [ __ ] know what appears to
mushroom ask him but I mostly estimate
what the South just why near passed
through him some almost pass through its
which miss Cora it was multiple to
suppose I just would provisional occur
to each machetes twelve organism neva is
this salad stuff just nation must put me
in terminal parasu post-operative
bankers called cheaper Veruca Egret up
is eco a classic romantic we do ship
with dementia Carter's run amok simple
scheme here we got all the Thunder be
stupid
what beautiful means really
yes Khalid in the machining of yes
co-led kotori's delayed my area in the
upwash to Yamaguchi relates his
reasoning was do to your bolio Susan ie
smoothly humanity it's a better idea the
cattle music YT work must practice when
we put upgrade that yes for the linear
programming theater stubborn asteroids
is where you robotics almost he exposed
to transponder stimulus token angry stop
also gives chemistries to Maria Magana
and with bullet illnesses
transhumanism is about self-control we
should strive to be perfect in every way
food is is horrible and we have some
projects in the Russian business
movement to actually get rid of food sex
is really overrated and once we move
from this biological existence to more
machine like resistance we'll forget
about sex very quickly in humans today
love is essentially addiction do you
love your wife yes I do love my wife but
I realize it's really extremely
dangerous because life is unpredictable
and just one step for love is hatred if
we can fix that it doesn't really matter
that we become different species what
matters is we can finally be happy
productive or creative we can control
what we want to do
my officiated roster news no prophet
Jesus that it's a minute what no great
and is means to me in you
conditional yeah her kilvo granulosa
what sir
gaddama merge with my coconut opposes
little more of near I thought [ __ ] need
mr. with the most Oh Mia interiors like
a Annika retreat in cinemas near
contractor Shawnee partisan no new
Virage Tony illusion Tomas de nuestro
supreme original master autonomy and
Kadam cash business Virginia grenade
olga Rastas neat process terenia valued
situation near sequential a short
musical genre - I know a bride for the
volute says reroute
I don't really want to replace humanity
with post humanity I'm a like other
people I want everybody to be happy but
I don't want everybody to be posthumous
I want myself to do that my friends to
do that maybe thousands of people maybe
tens of thousands I don't want everybody
to believe that there will be the top
here which I built for you maybe maybe
not
don't hope for that yes for me I'm not
afraid to this death is nothing and
there is no reason to be afraid of
nothing but I'm very curious I want you
to see with my own eyes what will be in
hannity as a thousand years maybe it
will be for good maybe it will be
you